hello everyone how's everybody doing
welcome to rational science
today we have a
short lecture
uh
kind of improvised because i changed the
subject matter i was going to do
something else today
but as a result of a um
a little uh debate little discussion
little uh analysis that we did with jf
gorippi uh yesterday yesterday night
really his friday my saturday
um i decided to change the subject i'm
gonna address these two issues
explanation and description
um
so i'm going to try to make it short
hopefully sweet
and uh if you have any questions on that
subject alone i'm going to see if i can
address it at the end of the uh lecture
okay
anyways uh first i'm gonna start with
some of the issues that we're dangling
from last time and it's got a lot to do
with the moon and the moonies
and flat earthers usually okay
in general that's
uh those are the people who oppose or
who object to the notion that humans
ever went to the moon but there are
people who are not
uh flat earthers uh we'll call them
moonies okay
and so the moonies also say that we
never went to the moon and they have
some other issues
as well with the moon and here's the
first issue fella says
he says uh
but the moon really spins
uh-huh
uh one revolution takes 28 of our days
that is why we are always the same
we always we
we see always the same face
um
if i did not if it did not spin you
would see a the back side of the moon in
14 days
okay so people believe that because the
moon
uh rotates around the earth always
showing the same face there is a eight
degree uh wobble there where you can see
eight degrees more of the moon once one
time and more and eight
degrees more of the other side of the
moon so the moon is actually wobbling a
little bit but essentially always shows
us the same phase so people have this
idea
that the moon does in fact spin
because it its spin matches its rotation
its orbit around the earth okay so even
though it always shows the same face
they say well the earth is sp
the moon is spinning because uh you know
it's constantly changing its uh
direction with respect to the earth as
it goes around the or as it orbits
around
and the answer is no
the moon does not spin under any
circumstance under any interpretation of
the word spin okay
and so let's move on to the second
fellow here who uh
also raises a similar issue
and uh he says the following he says uh
you believe the physical earth rotates
uh-huh yeah i think it does
it spins okay so now we're talking about
the earth not the moon okay
okay uh hopefully i'm still online i got
a message there from youtube saying that
uh there's some kind of problem uh
hopefully someone lets me know if you
can't hear me or see me i have no idea
why i get these messages from youtube
okay
as far as i know um
i'm online and everything checks out
okay okay so please let me know
otherwise
anyway the foul says you have been told
that since childhood uh i was
brainwashed but he's right on that in
that sense uh we are all told all told
since childhood
that um you know many things and we
accept them at face value because these
are the grown-ups who are teaching us
so this is true we are told a lot of
things since childhood among them that
the earth spans
and that the moon goes around the earth
etc
okay so we do receive this kind of
information in childhood when we were we
are children okay
okay thank you appreciate that i don't
know why i get the messages from youtube
anyways the file continues he says i
assume you have considered the direct
evidence
evidence
proof
okay
uh for that conclusion please tell me
the one in uh the one or two best
evidences
and evidence that convinced you that uh
physical earth is actually rotating
please explain why they convinced you
that it's rotating and i really would
like to know what you understand is
absolute convincing evidence for
rotating physical earth
these people think that science
uh is about convincing
and persuading and converting people and
they want to be convinced persuaded
through what evidence
they say run an experiment or do an
observation or or whatever it is
and convince me persuade me force me to
change my mind
this is the way they think
and we don't do that in science we don't
try to persuade or convince you of
anything okay so whenever you talk about
evidence and convincing proof those
kinds of words that belongs to religion
never raise them in this site okay
okay so what's the problem let's go one
problem at a time here we have the earth
spinning okay so we're going to answer
some of his questions the first one
we're gonna answer let's put it here
okay the earth uh is a globe
it has it's a spherical object celestial
object okay
and uh i uh the problem here is that i
always explain this to these folks and
they never come back none of these guys
none of these flat earthers ever come
back
to
they just throw the question like saying
well you can't answer it and and they
just leave and they so they never come
back to the to discuss the issue
you know so i don't understand uh are
they interested in in uh learning or not
you know i mean do they really want to
challenge their ideas or are they just
throwing the question because the air is
free okay so the earth is a globe why is
it a globe okay the first one is that
water and air
encapsulate our planet water and air
curve around
the earth
okay and they say prove it bill
okay we don't prove we give you an
explanation so that you understand it
whether you believe it or not that's
your personal business it doesn't
concern science at all okay so we don't
attack your
your uh credence your your faith your
your beliefs okay
okay so here's why
water and air curve around the earth
which means that the earth had better be
a sphere because that's the only way we
can explain what i'm going to show you
now okay
if you don't like what i show you you
should come back and say bill this is
what's wrong with it or attack it in
some way don't just throw the question
and leave which is what all these people
do okay here it goes okay
uh here's uh one atom of air okay
and you also have uh water there the the
blue stuff is water the uh the rings
that i put around the light blue there
those are air and what you see is atoms
being pulled towards the center of the
earth okay no matter how you look at
this you have all these atoms that form
our air and the same thing happens with
the water okay
and they're pulled always towards the
center of the earth
and again the farther out you go into
space the lighter the air becomes
there's fewer atoms as you go out until
at some point there are no more uh
oxygen uh atoms out there okay or o2 you
know air uh
the molecule of uh o2
and so what i'm saying is that the
reason the air the reason we have air
around the earth the reason uh mercury
um sorry uh mars has a co2 atmosphere
the reason uh
venus has a co2 atmosphere all these
gases stick around these planets it's
because every atom that comprises that
gas is
uh connected to every atom
uh of that body of that uh celestial
object in this case we have air and
every atom of the air is connected
physically connected by electromagnetic
ropes to every atom that comprises the
earth and of course you're supposed to
look at this in three dimensions it's
it's you're talking about a globe and
you're talking about all these nested
shells of air
and in the same way you're talking about
the nested shells of water
that um are in the oceans
as you go deeper you're gonna have
higher pressure because of that because
you have more and more concentration of
atoms down there okay of water and so
yeah what you have here is an
explanation of why the earth is round
and uh meaning spherical i'll call it
round but roundish in the sense of
spherical okay 3d
and why every atom of air does not leave
the earth and fly off into outer space
they're all physically connected to
every atom on earth and of course that's
always going to tug towards the center
because as you can see here every atom
is pulled from the other side even by
atoms of air on the other side of uh the
planet and if if you just do this
you'll find out that yeah everything
pulls towards the center and the center
should be the highest pressure of all
okay so that's uh
the best i can tell you uh the earth is
a sphere sorry for you flat earthers
okay so that's the first issue
now what's the other issue
okay let's put it here again uh
the earth also casts a curved shadow on
the moon
okay so uh every now and then uh the
earth uh
the sun hits the the earth and the earth
casts its penumbra onto the surface of
the moon okay so that and it's curved so
from that point of view you can imagine
that the earth is curved
and and then that shadow
you know moves across the surface of the
moon okay so apparently something is
moving out there now what's the issue
here the issue is that point there moon
changes locations what are we saying
there if if you look at the night sky
and you can film this if you want you
can take your binoculars and just
observe it for a little while you'll
find out that the moon changes locations
in the night sky it's not always at the
same place in the sky with respect to
other stars or whatever you see out
there the moon moves
in the night sky
if the moon moves then the earth
must of necessity move with respect to
the moon
okay one is moving in that direction
this one is moving in this direction
okay so whenever something moves in the
universe everything in the universe
moved or changed locations with respect
to that object
so the earth does move whether you like
it or not
okay if the moon moves in one direction
or anything in the universe moves in one
direction the earth automatically
changes its location to that point
and that means that the earth moves by
definition because the definition of
motion is two or more locations
okay so the earth is a globe and the
earth moves now
uh there we have it moon moves to the
left uh left to the right you know in
the night sky the sun moves left to
right in the base guy
well what does that imply well it means
that the globe earth right
spins left to right because uh the the
only
difference there between you know the
moon and the sun compared to the earth
is that the earth spins much faster than
the moon they all move in the same
direction in the case of moon and you
know the moon and the earth move in the
same direction except that the earth
rotates in 24 hours whereas the moon
takes 27 and some fractions of a day to
go around the earth so they're moving in
the same direction but you can imagine
if the earth rotates faster than the
moon
goes around it orbits
then of course the moon is going to be
shown going in the opposite direction
okay so that's why you know the
the the earth not only is a globe but
the earth moves and the earth spins it's
not that someone convinced me it's not
that someone uh produced some evidence
it comes through reasoning in science we
don't present evidence in science we
present arguments uh or theories that
explain uh behavior or or uh
phenomena
okay so that's the situation it's this
is not something about convincing or
persuading
or
you know brainwashing or anything like
that it's got to do strictly with
reasoning you have to reason it out okay
i have no power to go with a rocket out
there and look at the whole setup and
say yeah
after observing the moon for one
um full month i found that it does go
around the earth and meanwhile i saw the
earth spinning on its axis you know i
don't i can't do that so i have to do it
through reasoning
it's not through brainwashing it's
through reasoning you reason say okay if
the moon goes that way why does it go
that way well it goes that way maybe
because the earth is spinning faster
than the moon goes around it so yeah the
moon it always lags behind the spin of
the earth
okay
and again you know
spherical the earth does move
you don't feel it moving well i don't
see my carpet moving and you say well
the carpet doesn't move
well it does move with respect to
jupiter
my carpet moves with respect to jupiter
so my carpet does move every atom in the
universe had better be moving
because it's changing location with
respect to all other atoms in the
universe
everything moves there's no such thing
as non-motion in in
in our universe okay so everything moves
every atom moves every object moves with
respect to other objects because that's
the definition of the word move which is
two or more locations
okay
what is a location set of distances with
respect to all other objects so those
distances those separations
not numbers separations those
separations change sometimes you have a
bigger gap sometimes you have a smaller
gap that's called motion
okay
so everything moves whether you like it
or not every time you move your arm the
earth moves with respect to your arm so
you move the earth
okay so
please try to understand the definition
of the word motion move
okay
okay another fellow with this spin thing
a moonspin okay they try to give you the
idea that the moon spins
no the moon does not spin let's explain
it one more time let's see if someone
gets it out there okay
the moon rotates on its axis meaning
he's trying to suggest that the moon
spins okay the moon's rate of rotation
matches its orbital period which keeps
the same ray facing the same side facing
here okay so again all these people have
the idea that the earth spins
it does not spin let's let's explain one
more time like i did the other day why
the moon why the moon does not spin
on its axis okay we're gonna put a rod
right through the center of the moon
okay we're gonna put a rod right through
the center of the moon that rod is
cylindrical rod okay we'll call that the
axis in other words we'll make our axis
not one-dimensional as things are in
mathematical physics we're going to make
our our axis we're going to make it a
little wider we're going to make it into
a cylinder of some kind a very thin
cylinder that goes right through the
center of the moon and you can put that
rod any way you want you can put it
crosswise up and down east west north
south i don't care put it any way you
want okay here's the deal the rod is
colored okay it's got blue on one side
and it's got red on the other side okay
and we're going to leave the rod fixed
okay so the rod is going to stand still
the rod is not going to move
that way we can have we can gauge
the motion of the moon with respect to
the rod which has been uh
impaled
right through the moon
okay
right running right through it
now one mountain any mountain that you
want on the moon
does not change
its location with respect to red or blue
and another mountain on the other side
of the moon does not change its location
ever with respect to the red or the blue
okay
so
so the moon does not spin with respect
to that axis
that little cylinder that i just you
know impaled in there okay that's what
i'm saying the moon can change its
location or or
you know its orbit might match its uh
its so-called spin its rotation
but the moon is not spinning with
respect to its internal axis if we could
put a stake right through it and we
color code that stake
the mountains on the edges of the moon
do not change
their location with respect to those two
colors
they're always gonna they're always
gonna rotate together
okay and that's different than what you
see in in the earth this is the earth
okay
let me get it up here
see the the axis on the earth rotates
with the earth if i drew that stake
right through the earth that state would
be spinning as well that's not the case
with the moon the moon's axis does not
spin so to speak okay that's what i'm
trying to say here okay
i hope someone understood
okay
and
you know don't just repeat
that oh the moon spins the moon spin no
no answer the question
does
one side of the moon
change with respect to the color coded
uh cylinder or
axis that i put in through the center of
the earth
either it does or it doesn't okay it's a
yes or no type of question okay very
simple
okay and so the moon does not spin
spinning would mean that the axis
itself rotates somehow if we could drive
a stake through there and it that's not
the case
okay
an independent one by the way right
don't tell me that is a strip of land
going through the center of the moon
we're not talking about that we're
talking about an imaginary axis
uh
you know cylinder we just drove this
stake right through the moon and we're
hold that one standing still does the
moon rotate with respect to that
cylinder the answer is no
it does not rotate with respect to that
artificial cylinder that stands still
while the moon rotates around it doesn't
happen
okay
okay here we have uh
another foul who talks about whether
humans went into went to the moon
okay we have these moonies out there
okay and fella says it's impossible
because of the radiation from the sun
and a lot of people have this argument
okay they they support this argument and
they said it's like putting corn seeds
in the microwave after a while they turn
into
popcorn
[Laughter]
there is currently no such thing as
protecting living organism from
radiation invading the black sky okay he
calls it the black sky
it's called space but i don't know maybe
in his language it's known as the black
sky
okay
what can we say well you know uh we have
protection in microwave ovens
for uh
for all kinds of radiation i mean if if
you bring microwave radiation at least
which is not as high as some other
radiations right like gamma rays or
whatever uh you have ways of protecting
whatever you put in the oven uh against
that high frequency radiation
and all i can tell you here is uh look
up the following and i'm just going to
give you some clues here what a
spacesuit is made of what materials
protect you against high level radiation
out there in space okay this is how a
suit is built okay and here it is you
have uh spacesuit materials that they
use to build them right to construct
them
um
uh tricot material uh you have span
spandex okay
uh urethane coated nylon okay dacron
dacron ductron uh synthetic fabrics such
as neoprene which is a sponge rubber
aluminized mylar uh gortex cobbler uh
no mix all these are materials that are
put into these spacesuits okay they also
have fiberglass they have uh lithium
hydroxide okay silver zinc
plastic tubing and polycarbonate which
are used for the helmet
you know so these guys are well
protected against the so-called
radiation
and uh you know once again you don't
have to believe in this you don't have
to go out there to even to nasa to find
out if this is true or not just put
something in your oven especially some
metal
and find out if it absorbs the radiation
yeah and you'll find out that it does
that we have materials that protect
against high level radiation okay so to
say that you know
we could not withstand uh radiation from
the sun out there you know radiation
first of all you know you have to
understand another thing
the um when you're out there in the
middle of space like between the earth
and the moon right
halfway between well you're really in
the middle of space you're in the middle
of nowhere
and you're subjected to what is known as
a solar wind the solar wind is very
tenuous i mean it's got what minus 12
maybe minus 13 torr range
you're talking about very few particles
per
cubic meter okay that's first that's the
first issue the second one is that
sometimes you don't have only you know
uh
the density of particles in that region
but you have maybe some swift moving
particles that might serve as a bullet
that goes right through you and some of
those might as well but those are very
few and far apart
and so you know there there's uh again
like in the capsule you're protected
from that outside the capsule you may
not be as well protected but obviously
you know
when when these astronauts are out there
the chances of getting hit by by a
boulder is like it never happens even if
you have a little uh zooming atom go
right through you well we have that even
here on earth we're bombarded by uh
particles that go right through the
atmosphere you know it doesn't
it's not a foolproof protection that we
receive from our atmosphere and they'll
just go through your body maybe hit one
dna you know one atom out of the dna out
of whack and then that dna starts
growing
uh you know in a lousy way which is
known as you know uh
what is it uh when
uh i had in the tip of my tongue a
minute ago uh it's uh when you
uh
what's the word i'm looking for anyway
it changes your your contexture you know
it means that the next uh
generation of dna won't grow in the same
way okay so
so you have these changes in your body
why because you do get bombarded by
atoms from outer space that are not
blocked by our air
okay another fellow says nasa is now
trying to return astronauts to the moon
under our ms program for the first time
since 1972
program is uh
led by international human space flight
program its primary goal is to return
humans to the moon specifically the
lunar month uh south pole by 2025 and
your ms pro
program would create a permanent
presence on around the moon
okay you know uh i'm saying that we're
probably never gonna go to the moon
again maybe we will you know i mean i
think we have the
technology the ability to get back to
the moon
um
why would we go would we go to mine i
mean there are many reasons for going
what are we going to evacuate the earth
and go to the moon never going to happen
okay so forget about that are we going
to be out there in mind the moon you
know maybe take some
heavy machinery of some kind
mind the moon and bring the rocks back
well again uh if it's if there's
something that we're missing on earth we
would probably do it and if it's
critical
but again you gotta look at the cost
because to take someone to the moon just
to mine something and bring it back it's
a ton of money
besides the fact that if you do with
humans at least you can do it with
robots but if you do with humans
you know you get the the insurance and
all that stuff for those guys that go
out there okay so you got to think uh
you got to make sure your technology
works properly
and
you know again what are the returns what
are you going to get from them all you
would do it if if
it's worth it if it's
you know if it's profitable in some way
i don't know let's assume you're
bringing uranium okay back to the earth
because there's not enough uranium on
earth or because it's all gone and it's
all
uh
you know their half-lives are all uh
shot out
and so now you need more uranium on
earth and you say well let's get it from
the moon and let's let's say we found a
lot of it on the moon so we send some
machinery out there and we start mining
it okay that might be a worthwhile
venture again if it's worth our money
the global treasury invested on on such
an operation otherwise why would we go
to the moon i mean we have to uh
you know supply these people out there
in in a little cabin you know some kind
of cabin that we build there we call it
a station or whatever and the guys got
to be there like you know on their on
these orbiting stations these guys would
have to be out there for a long time
so several months for sure
and they would have to work under
extreme conditions where you know they
would have to
dress up every time they go out go with
the machinery think of these guys
working more or less like you know these
uh bulldozers and
other equipment that they have you know
the cranes and so on that they used to
bring down buildings and
raise new buildings out there they would
have to work with heavy machinery to
mine the moon bring it into their little
place there and then from there put it
on the next capsule that comes over and
take that to earth so that we could use
it here on earth
you know uh
just
ponder the costs
and again it would have to be some
material we don't have on earth which is
very very unlikely okay and again i
think extinction is going to catch us
way before that ever happens so yeah
they might have some projects to go to
the moon i don't think they'll ever
materialize that's my five cents worth
on that
okay final issue uh regarding uh these
uh the extinction phase of the lecture
pal says the past extinction level
events didn't do a very good job because
we are still here
okay uh let's see what he's about
extension is the completely wrong word
for describing said event
as it more akin to a mass culling and
and i'm talking in the context of life
no matter what form it takes
no extinction level event ever happened
as extinct means the end of all life and
obviously that has never happened
well he's got a peculiar definition of
the word extinction now extinction we
use it uh per species
and we use it also for families and
orders and so the question is if
extinction is the end of all life on
earth meaning including plants and
everything then what we call you know um
uh when an order or a family of plants
or animals goes away what do we call it
when one
species of plants and animals disappears
what kind of word are we going to use
for that that's the word we use that's
what we use the word extinction for and
if not then you have to give me a word
that we can use in science
okay
okay let's move on to the issue of
explanation and description and let me
tell you why i brought it up i had an
interview yesterday with uh jf gorippi
uh canadian who has a channel
and we discussed several things about
the rope model one of the things that
took us there or one of the i guess
introductory issues
was this
notion of explanation and description
and he's not the only one who has it a
lot of people think that an explanation
description are synonyms
that there is no difference between
explanation description okay and so
let's clarify that i think that's an
important point let me tell you why
it's an important point because uh we
define here uh science as rational
explanations
so we had better know what an
explanation is and it's not rational
descriptions okay
descriptions is what mathematics does
you know really mathematical physics
uh what they do is descriptions they
don't do explanations they do
explanations really but all the
explanations are irrational in other
words no explanation at all they harp on
descriptions and so we don't do
descriptions in science we do
explanations so we had better understand
the difference between an explanation
and a description and that subject came
up last night okay and so people a
couple people who obviously watch the
show ask some questions about that and
uh one fellow says when the discussion
begins begins with your opponent not
understanding the difference between an
explanation and a description
you know you're in for a tough fight
uh yeah that's uh i think uh first point
that we gotta
highlight we need to
not agree
we don't have to agree but we have to
zero in
on a definition of explanation and
description
and hopefully you know uh you can defend
your definition okay that's that's how
we do it in science you don't you don't
say well everybody voted for my
definition
or you know or for my notion of
explanation or my notion of description
that's not how we do it in science the
way we do it in science you have to get
inside the ring with your shield and
your sword and you have to fight for
your definition if someone pokes holes
in your definition while you get
accepted reality okay maybe you don't
but a lot of people will okay
okay and uh at least science will okay
okay so uh another foul says the
following he says jfg is convinced by
ignorance
that describe and explain our synonym
synonyms and therefore mean the same
thing uh poor fool
and like him there are very good
university professors and presumed
intellectual who do not understand what
they are saying in that sense i will
agree with this follow um
a lot of professors out there they think
description and explanation are the same
thing one famous professor which i
constantly uh
you know reference uh donald simenek
he's from uh pennsylvania university
and he makes it clear he says
science doesn't
explain
science describes
so apparent he notices that there is a
difference between explanation and
description and because he's a
mathematician he talks about science
being descriptions because that's what
mathematical physics has turned science
into over the centuries since at least
the 17th century
scientific so-called scientific
revolution right quotations on that
and
what what has come out of that is that
they say that science is about
describing
because that's what mathematics does
that's all that mathematics can do an
equation is only a description
and so science has
drifted into this world in which it's
all descriptions
and we're seeing something different
we're creating a
paradigm shift starting this century and
we're saying no science is not
description science is not math science
is not just doing an experiment not
understanding anything and say oh let me
describe the experiment
and the guy gets a nobel prize for that
he says i discovered such and such
things such as such
behavior i observed it
that's not science you know it's like
saying i observe the wall this black
wall here i'm the first one to observe
it give me my noble
no no just because you observed because
you bumped into a wall you were the
first to discover the wall you do not
become a scientist
and so we're saying that description is
not science explanation is science and
so yeah we have better understand the
difference between an explanation and a
description okay so the fellow continues
says and like him okay he says uh to
describe to re i guess he took this from
a dictionary okay because he just
uh puts the etymology of uh of uh these
words and so he just copied and pasted
and the problem with that is that you
won't find a single scientific
definition in any dictionary on planet
earth
okay so
if you go out there and just copy and
paste you're gonna copy nonsense again
you have to get in the ring and be able
to fight and defend your definitions you
can't just copy and paste and say i
found it in the dictionary it doesn't
mean that because you found it in the
dictionary that's the that's a
scientific definition of that word okay
that we can use it in science and that's
the problem here the file says to
describe to represent in words a place
an object a person noting its aspects
and qualities etc explain what is to
explain to declare with words uh uh make
explicit clearly expressed with words
clearly manifest one's thought of or
feelings make understand
uh clarify make understandable something
that is not simple or
is even obscure
we can't use any of this nonsense none
of it so all this goes into the trash
can together with your entire dictionary
yeah we don't need these definitions
because none of these can be defended by
a scientist okay so no these are not the
definitions of the word uh
describe or uh explain okay or
description and explanation
okay so uh what did good old jfg say
okay
and i'm gonna correct some of these
people here jfg did not say that
description and explanation are actually
synonyms that's not what he said okay
what he suggested is that explanation
includes a series of descriptions
ultimately that it's just a series of
descriptions that was his argument okay
so he's saying you know
he couldn't he says he's interested in
mechanism not in descriptions but
throughout his schooling he came to the
conclusion that explanations are just a
bunch of descriptions you know one right
after another and that's what i'm going
to challenge i'm going to challenge that
notion okay so
that's what this lecture is about
okay so here's uh john francois jf as we
call him cheaper than saint john
francois okay
and he said the following these are his
words okay any mechanistic explanation
will boil down to a description of the
mechanism that's the first thing he said
there he suggests that they're more or
less synonyms okay but then he continued
he says mechanisms are met meta made uh
descriptions okay and then he went on
and he said explanation is made up of
little other descriptions
okay so his notion is that an
explanation is just a set
of descriptions
that's
his overall feeling for that that's his
conclusion after studying in uh at the
university okay okay
so this is what he comes up with i'm
saying that's not
what an explanation
is it's close in many ways but not quite
it doesn't make the mark okay okay so
where are the def the differences first
let me pull again the definition that we
find in the dictionary i found this in a
dictionary a different dictionary this
other fellow to make plain or clear
render clear render understandable or
intelligible that's what an explanation
is well is understanding the same thing
explained as
explaining okay
uh one is on the receiving end the other
one on the emitting end okay so we can't
really i don't think we can use the word
understand
to define the word ex explain because
they're like
um when you have negatives of a word you
can't say that you know a horse is a
non-dog or it's not a dog yeah
that's a bad definition for a horse you
know because a horse is not a tree
either you know and so on so you can't
use negatives to define because using
synonyms or antonyms is forbidden in
science here we have a more or less the
same situation we're saying that what is
on one end the emitting end the other
one's on the receiving end so explain is
what the emitting end has and
understanding what the receiving end has
i don't think you can define the word
explain
using the word understand okay then it
says to assign meaning
well what do you mean by meaning
uh does everybody have the same meaning
for example right to interpret
okay
and interpret i like a little better
okay because it's i think closer to my
notion of what
the word explanation has to do with okay
and that's the one i'm going to use
essentially to
uh
debunk the notion that uh jf has uh that
a an explanation is just a series of
descriptions okay
and uh
then i like the other one cause or
reason of okay
yeah uh you know the the word describe
fits but awkwardly with with the words
uh cause and reason
cause and reason you know uh that's
kinda you know you can't say i'm gonna
describe the cause i'm gonna describe
the reason it kind of doesn't fit in
there you gotta use the word explain a
cause explain a reason okay these are
explanations and describe doesn't fit
with that so here we see a little bit
uh
of difference between the word explained
and the word describe and sometimes
examples are good to put us in the right
you know uh context
what is describe well to give an account
uh uh to label
again you know
what what is uh a description like you
describe a chair and you say it's black
all you did is assign a word to it you
labeled it okay so in that sense yeah
describe is just a label and that's not
exactly what an explanation is
then it says to denote and to picture or
figure in other words you present an
image of something okay and so if if you
present an image you you we talk about
describing an image right a scene
and what do you do you just name the
things that are on the scene maybe you
say what color they are you know you put
some adjectives in there to
embellish the scene so that
you you paint a good picture for the
audience
okay so in that sense uh explain
and describe show you two different
aspects one has to do with causes and
reasons i'm going to add mechanisms and
the other one has to do with just
painting a picture
of
objective what you saw
okay in in that picture or in a series
even in a series of pictures but all
you're doing is describing the objects
that are in there maybe by color maybe
by texture by size you're just
describing and what are you going to use
you're going to use adjectives okay
primarily adjectives
okay so that's our starting point okay
just to put you in the right uh
frame of mind
okay uh so where do we go from here uh
give me a second here
clean this up
okay so um
here's where i'm gonna start uh i'm
gonna apply it first not to physics
apply it to philosophy
okay and under philosophy we deal with
reasons and purposes
under this in this site right and
physics deals with
um you know causes and mechanisms so
here you deal with objects and in
philosophy you deal really with concepts
what's the issue the issue is that
if i'm good because we have explanations
in philosophy as well okay so you have
to explain why someone did something
you're talking about purposes and
reasons
now uh
here's an example that i'm going to put
forth and it's got to do with a
famous little tale little uh novel
they turned it into movies and so on and
i think a lot of you are familiar with
it's known as romeo and juliet okay so
here are romeo and juliet and they fell
in love okay
and then they eventually ended up
committing suicide they killed
themselves okay
and what's the issue here well the issue
is that you know if you look at the
movie of this right uh we start out
somewhere in the movie where they uh
where they kiss and they fall in love
right there's no explanation for that so
now don't ask me to explain that one but
then the question is why did they commit
suicide you know how did they end up on
that last frame of the last few frames
where they commit suicide okay
and so you know you can have different
theories okay now the the writer the
author of these of this novel you know
he can come up with different scenarios
and he can give you an idea he can show
you the movie and he can even
uh paint a picture of what's happening
more or less in each frame of the film
inside his novel in the chapters right
he can paint a good picture and say this
is what they were thinking about they
were all worried about their families
not liking each other etc etc they can
go through all that whole thing and
and still you know some people might
have questions say well why did they
commit suicide well it could have been
because they finally decided that
you know they didn't really like each
other that they weren't meant for each
other another person might say well
their families
their respective families hated each
other and uh you know
you can come up with different theories
different explanations of what was going
through their minds
but you cannot really paint a good
picture of that either in a book or
in a uh in a movie you know you got to
show the scenes and a lot of people are
going to watch that and maybe interpret
something differently from you know what
one person interprets it might be
different than when another one
interprets they might both come out of
the movie and say so uh they committed
suicide because of this the other guy
said well that's not what i understood i
understood a different thing i thought
they they committed suicide because of
that
okay so they might have different
opinions but let me go even deeper uh
there's a detective and he goes to a
scene of a crime and then you know they
bring all this evidence into court and
the prosecutor is going to explain
why these people committed a crime or
why these people
did whatever they did what what was
going through their minds
and he has no pictures to show the
the uh
jurors
so he's gonna have to interpret
what he thinks was going through the
minds of the criminal or whatever
happened
he's gonna have to try to interpret what
was the reason what was the purpose
for this rape for this uh guy who killed
or for whatever
crime was committed he's going to have
to interpret what was going through the
mind of the criminal
okay so
you know how do you put that into words
and again it's an interpretation another
person you know the defense might
attorney you know he might come up with
a different theory of what was going
through the minds of the criminal
and so they have these different
theories maybe put more people in there
they all come up with even more theories
and so you can't really
just by watching the movie just by
looking at the scenes you're not going
to get a full picture of what was going
through the minds there's no way you can
always put all the details that's going
to the minds of a person
into words or into a picture
and so
that's the part that you cannot really
describe
okay you cannot describe that invisible
stuff that's going through people's
minds especially with purposes and
reasons so it's easier maybe to explain
it with philosophy but let's go to
physics let's find out we can try to
make sense of this uh
explanation description dichotomy in
in physics okay okay so here we have a
uh a situation we have gravity okay
and uh so
we don't see all the objects there and
so someone has to interpret that movie
if you look at the frames you know uh
just individually well then uh jf g
might be right he says look uh it's just
a bunch of descriptions uh that whole
movie if you look at one frame it says
this guy is far away he's got a distance
from the center of the earth and he
weighs one kilogram as the guy
approaches the earth now he weighs 25
kilograms the distance between the
center of the earth and the astronaut uh
is even closer now he weighs 50
kilograms and then he's very close to
the center of the earth or as close as
he can get to the center of the earth
and there he weighs 100 kilograms okay
so you watch this movie
and you say well
what is gravity and the guy says well
you know as you approach the earth uh
what you have this acceleration which we
call gravity and the guy weighs more and
more because the distance between him
and the center of the earth decreases
and that's what essentially what uh
newton's uh formula uh the gravitational
formula describes it says that uh when
you have these two masses if the
distance between them is
smaller and smaller then the force is
going to be greater so force and
distance are inversely proportional
great
and what have we learned do we know the
mechanism just by watching that movie
i mean we have descriptions in each one
of those uh frames and all we're saying
is if distance changes
then gravity changes or the force of
gravity the you know acceleration
changes
you weigh differently at different
locations but we haven't understood the
mechanism we don't have a mechanism even
though we have all the frames there and
we can describe each frame with luxury
of details
and and so again there you have a
description a bunch of descriptions and
we still don't have an explanation
okay so that's the first one i want to
point out to uh
that i don't think you can just say that
an explanation is a bunch of a series of
descriptions okay but let's move on
let's see if we can zero in a little
closer okay
here we have the rope model okay
and so now we're going to give you an
explanation of what causes what the
mechanism is okay let's focus on the
mechanism this time around you don't
have to believe it i'm just putting it
here so that you understand it okay so
here it is we have this astronaut now
he's falling uh towards earth okay and
again we have one thousand ropes in one
case he's closer he's got a million rows
because they're fanning out
then it goes to 1 billion into 1
trillion ropes okay so that's the notion
of gravity that we have
so jfg would probably say okay we have
we still have a description for your
explanation all we have in each frame
is a bunch of ropes and the ropes get
wider okay and so the astronaut
as he approaches the earth there are
more independent ropes he says it's just
a series of descriptions so even in this
case he says they're just descriptions
okay so that's that would be probably
his argument okay
and i don't want to put words in java's
mouth but i think this is the way he's
thinking okay that
all we're talking about is description
description here description here
description here and here
and so what is an explanation of a
mechanism it's just a series of
descriptions okay so in the first case
we we did not know what caused it all we
say is the guy weighs differently at
different locations and that's just a
bunch of descriptions no explanation no
mechanism here we have a mechanism we
say okay we have all these ropes and as
the guy gets closer the ropes widen out
there's more ropes essentially because
every rope every atom in his body is
connected to every atom on earth so as
the guy approaches the earth the ropes
fan out and so they're not on the same
axis because they fan out each one is
acting independently and because they
act independently the guy as he gets
closer to the earth he weighs more and
and he is accelerating okay and so we
call that gravity okay but so jf would
say okay bill all you did was put me a
whole bunch of descriptions
and that's what the next what your
explanation is that's what your
mechanism is just more ropes as the guy
approaches earth
and
again we have the issue of
interpretation which you don't get with
description okay and this is the issue
and let me put this up here
uh
here we have a description what you see
is in each frame
okay that that's what a description is
okay
and if you add these up in other words
if you put all these uh frames in a row
and you say okay i'm gonna make a movie
of this and i'm gonna show how the
astronaut falls to earth the ropes fan
out there's ever more ropes acting
between the uh planet and the astronaut
well then
then we have a series of descriptions
but the issue here is that an
explanation is the entire movie that's
you know you need the whole you can't
just look at one of those frames and say
you understood gravity and you can't
look at all these frames because again
you don't know if there's a different
interpretation here what if the ropes
are elastic what if they stretch
what if the ropes are coiling and the
more you coil them the links become
shorter and because of that that's
causing the
for the astronaut to fall faster towards
earth
so you can have different
interpretations meaning you can have
different theories different
explanations for the same for what
you're staring at there okay and so that
that's something you cannot necessarily
always be able to describe
in in
when you're trying to explain gravity
you have to clarify uh what the
mechanism is and the mechanism has to do
with interpretation and again you can
have different explanations different
theories for the same uh observation
which does not really mean that you have
the true
mechanism that mother nature has out
there you know you you can look at for
example gas coming out of
like a car works okay you say well
here's the gas tank here's the pipe
being here's the uh carburetor here's
the uh
pistons and so on and here are the
wheels okay and
two people can watch that same movie how
the gas goes in there goes all the way
to where the wheels move and they can
have a different interpretation a
different theory of what made those
wheels turn around
okay
and so
just watching the movie is not
sufficiently but
for sure for sure the theory the
explanation is the entire movie you
can't just look at one and say okay
here's the gas tank
okay does that tell you how the car ran
no you can't and you can't look at any
of those individual frames and say that
you understood
how the car ran you need all
the whole thing
and then descriptions are each frame in
the film and here you have the frame in
the film all in front of you and that
doesn't mean you understood the theory
in order to understand the theory you
have to get the movie rolling the tape
has to be rolling so that you can see
the mechanism you see what's happening
and description is something static
essentially you're describing a um
a scene
a
you know a an image
whereas a an explanation is a movie
so you know you have you have to set the
film in motion in order to understand
the mechanism you can't just watch
many frames still frames and say i
understand a mechanism because again you
don't know if maybe the ropes are
stretching the case of gravity under the
rope model you don't have the ropes are
stretching if they're coiling and that's
bringing the two objects together or if
they're like you know under my version
which is that all the ropes have just
tension between them they're not
stretching uh they're not coiling in a
sense that because they're coiling one
object is pulled closer none of that
there is no pull okay so there are
different interpretations and i'm saying
that you know each one of these is a
different theory for the same
thing that we saw and the only way we
can really understand it is by watching
the movie and not by watching just still
frank just staring at still frames okay
and which is what a series of
descriptions is so no i i differ i beg
to differ
with mr jfg i respect him but uh i i
don't agree with his notion of what um
an explanation is it's not just a series
of descriptions okay let me move on here
to the my definition my conclusion of
what
uh the definitions of these two words
are
and i'm gonna clarify after my talk with
him i think i'm going to revise them
maybe i need to revise them i don't know
yet i'm going to be looking at it this
week because for me it's an important
subject okay but uh here's what i have
to date this is out of my book okay and
it says description a listing of
properties of an image okay so you're
just describing what you're
staring at in a given image that's a
description okay and what is an equation
it's a snapshot
you get only one value in a
in an equation and so again an equation
even though it's uh
the equation describes motion
for each uh
value that you put you know that you
replace the uh variables with
you get only one
uh point on the chart
if you want to see that thing moving you
got to set the film in motion okay and
even then you only have a description in
the case of math you don't have an
explanation of why that dot moved the
way it moved okay
and then what is an explanation the
causes in case of physics right reasons
in case of philosophy
underlying a phenomenon uh
and a synonym is the word theory theory
and escalation are exact synonyms
under the rope under the
scientific method the true genuine
scientific method an explanation is the
prosecutor's version of how or why a
consummated event happened
okay that's not what a description is
description uh might tell you what
where uh what happened you know just one
car hit the other
a an explanation tells you why what
caused it to happen what triggered it
okay and you can't you know again causes
and reasons um they don't match the word
description
you can't say with with the word
description or describe right that
you're going to come to the uh
causes or reasons that uh triggered a uh
a phenomenon to happen okay so this is
where we differ with uh with jfg i'm
saying that
um
an explanation has a little more than
just a series of descriptions each frame
in the film is a description okay in the
case of um
uh you know the current status of
mathematical physics where they can't
see or
or touch
the mediators that mediate you know the
secret agents mother nature uses to do
gravity uh all they do is use math and
that's just going to be end up with a
description so even though you see the
frames on the film you say okay i saw
the frames on the film i still don't
know what caused that to happen all i
have is a description per frame
in the case of the rope model you have
an explanation but it's you can't just
synthesize it in which in
in frames of the film you can't just
look at the frames of the film and say
yeah i know what happened
or what caused it to happen now you need
a little interpretation there because
you gotta clarify to the observer the
person who's watching your your or
staring at each frame of the film you
have to explain to him
the mechanism uh that you know not only
that as an object approaches another you
have these tight ropes but that they
don't stretch you know and something
that he's not just going to get from
looking at the movie
you're going to have to add that
interpretation to his understanding okay
so that you have a full what is known as
explanation a full mechanism of what
happened before you
okay
anyways uh i'm gonna just answer one
question and someone
asked uh other topic okay but i just
wanted to address this question uh and
i'll address all others that people made
or if if i didn't address your question
today just raise it again next time okay
that's all i can say
okay and fellow says bill how do you
conclude that knowledge is equal to
belief
how do you attribute this to plato or
the socrates who is probably already
discussing it with his teacher aristotle
poor bella
no no aristotle was 15 years old when
socrates died i don't think aristotle
was socrates teacher okay no socrates
was the uh teacher of plato who was the
teacher of aristotle okay that's the way
it went uh aristotle came years after uh
socrates that's the first thing we have
to clarify okay but then he says you
wrote this [ __ ] in your slide in a
video prior to this one uh yeah and uh
so where did i get all this where did i
get the knowledge is equal to belief
well i'm not the owner of of that and
i'm not going to take responsibility for
proclaiming this okay here's where i got
it okay everybody over here okay
and uh this is where i got it from says
plato argued that there was a
distinction between knowledge and true
belief in the theater
what is it theaters i can't even
pronounce that thing leading many to
attribute to justify true belief okay so
this is the wikipedia you can find it
there i didn't invent this i didn't put
it in there okay
uh people have throughout the ages
interpreted plato is saying that uh
knowledge is true justified true belief
you get that also in the sanford
encyclopedia philosophy where they deal
with the word knowledge you can look
that up and a famous fellow edmund
gettier he came up with a notion that
justified true belief which he
attributes to plato is not sufficient to
uh
define the word knowledge okay so he
made a full analysis and then
i again welcome you to
look it up okay you don't have to take
my word for it i didn't invent this
notion but let me tell you one thing
according to
uh plato and according to everyone ever
since the days of plato since the days
of the greek
um
uh
knowledge is belief
what does what does knowledge mean
forget about all the definitions just
think for a second try to use your brain
okay and what is knowledge now this
means you have nothing more to know
nothing more to learn about a given
subject because you already know it
but it turns out someone else
says well i don't i have i don't have a
different notion of what you just said
that guy knows something different
so this guy knows that the earth is flat
and the other guy knows the earth is
round this guy knows that god exists the
other guy knows that god doesn't exist
so everybody knows
what does nose mean
believe means that you know and no one's
going to change your mind because you
believe it and you're certain of your
belief
so yeah knowledge is belief and there is
no other definition for the word
knowledge
so gettier and all these other people
they're running around in circles
knowledge is belief it's always been
belief and that's why no one can define
it otherwise
with that i'll see you next time
bye bye well let's see if uh anyone
raises anything about explanations i'll
look real quick and i'll be glad to
answer
okay
okay spin uh i'll address that next time
explain someone says make clear to
someone by describing
okay well i think i addressed that my
point of view okay
okay looks like uh no one had any
question but if you have a question
regarding explain
and describe certainly would like to
hear about it and uh
i do hope that you put the
question there okay we'll see you next
time bye bye